it was an emotional speech in the rose
garden at the white house
in which joe biden laid out in front of
gun shooting survivors
what's at stake america is dealing with
an epidemic of violence
the idea that we have so many people
dying every single day from gun violence
in america
there's a blemish on our character as a
nation
the new measures are limited in scope
but it is a statement of intent from the
presidency
sales of so-called ghost guns will be
restricted
these are self-assembled weapons ordered
online
another rule targets the sale of
stabilized braces for pistols
the suspect in the recent shooting in
colorado allegedly used one on a rampage
which left
10 dead joe biden made a campaign
promise that he'd tackled gun violence
early in his term
but with his path blocked in congress by
republicans and conservative democrats
he's having to rely on executive actions
the fiat of presidential power
but without support elsewhere that's
only going to take him so far
on an issue that he has described as a
national
embarrassment victims of gun violence
say there is still a long way to go
but this is a welcome start my best
friends went with me to pulse on june 12
2016 my brothers my chosen family
and they didn't come home they will
forever be missing faces at my birthday
parties
every time something incredible happens
in my life and i pick up my phone
to call my best friend i know he's not
going to answer and so to have
the president of the united states
standing at that podium talking about
the same common sense gun safety reforms
that we've been fighting for so hard
it's a it's a wave of relief
but the national rifle association
called joe biden's speech
a circus and an attempt to dismantle the
second amendment
in a country where guns are enmeshed
into the way of life
and what it means to be american there
is huge resistance
it's an infringement on your personal
right to
keep and bear firearms you can bear
tools people look at
they demonize firearms and to what
purpose a firearm is no different than a
hammer or a spatula
the powerful gun lobby argues that there
are already enough laws in place
but with more than a hundred americans
dying every day
this new administration knows it must do
something
in a country which for the large part
remains
in denial alex rossi sky news
washington